King Charles met with President Biden on Monday for the second time since he ascended the throne last
year.
This meeting mirrored a similar one between the president and the late queen in 2021 and
continues a long tradition of Anglo American diplomatic photo ops.
Charles may just be getting into the swing of these things as monarch.
But his experience of us presidents goes back a long way.
He was just 10 when he met President Dwight D Eisenhower,
his presidential get togethers since then,
have highlighted the importance of the royal family as vital diplomatic tools for the UK.
But they've also given him a platform to campaign on issues close to his heart,
something he will need to rein in now that he is king.
The future king's first visit to the US was in 1970 America to
me and my sister has always been a very fascinating and
intriguing country.
It was a visit that President Richard Nixon hoped would be a public relations bonanza,
an indication of the closeness of the relationship between the United
States and Great Britain and the British Commonwealth.
It was one of Charles's early experiences of engaging in a form of diplomacy known as soft power,
soft power is the power of attraction rather than military or financial
might.
And this is that the British royal family really excels at the American public is very
interested in seeing them.
And so when Charles came as Prince of Wales,
he was much younger and he really had that star power.
It was like when the Beatles descended because he was this very young,
attractive 20 something year old Prince.
He would later reference that first visit during a White House trip.
35 years later,
the media were busy trying to marry me off to Trisha Nixon.
That event hosted by President George W Bush also gave the prince a platform to touch on more
serious matters.
So many people throughout the world look to the United States of America
for a lead on the most crucial issues that face our planet.
He also praised then first lady Michelle Obama's campaign against childhood obesity and
hunger.
These are marvelous ideas that I'm sure will make a major difference and he has not shied away
from using his presidential interactions to promote issues important to him.
One of the great examples is that he did bring up climate change when he met with President Donald Trump.
Well,
we're going to have a 15 minute chat and it turned out to be an hour and a half and he
did most of the talking.
There's been discussions about why this is,
but at the end of the day,
it might just be more straightforward and more simple is that he had the ear of one of the most powerful people on the
planet and decided this was his issue and try to convince him to follow suit.
Now,
as King Charles must remain politically neutral and he has acknowledged that he cannot continue as a
campaigner.
It will no longer be possible for me to give so much of my time and
energies to the charities that issues for which I care so deeply.
I think he'll still press his issues privately with either the President States or his prime minister
and push his own agenda and say those things.
And when it comes to being a soft power tool,
he has a lot to live up to the queen was by far the master of soft power.
She was a very skilled diplomat in many ways.
And part of that is because she had 70 years of experience with Charles.
We'll have to see now if he really steps into his mother's shoes and balance those
public and private outings.
Charles's ascension to the throne comes at a time when the UK is seeking stronger economic and security
ties with the US.
The UK really has to rely on the British Royal family to sort of promote brand Britain and to
keep up U UK relations.
King Charles may have to cut back on the speeches but there seems no end in sight for the presidential photo
ops.